okay good morning everyone okay first
thing I have to say that this title
might scare some people off so my fault
I should have chosen a better title but
I hope that as I go along with the
presentation you can understand better
what was doing here and the at least you
agree is to pick up the paper on which
this talk is but it's done so let's
start what our semantic relationships
let's imagine that we have this just
it's raw text and we assume ins we can
read it and we can understand it what's
going on here we have a sentence about
Noam Chomsky about both Audrey and about
Barack Obama delves the places where
they studied where they lived
but for computers this is just a bunch
of strings in text I mean there's no
there's no information like semantic
information here for the computers we
have distracted piece by piece and one
of the first things that we can do is
just apply a named entity recognizer and
we get all the person names all the
locations and all the organizations and
now what we are interesting to do is to
see that for each pair of named entities
where they are related in relation or
not and clearly we can see on the first
one it between norm sham skin and East
Oakland it says that it was the place of
birth of norm Kamsky on the second
sentence we can see that was orange
studied at the MIT and and so forth so
semantically relationship extraction
just looking at these pairs of named
entities in the textual context where
they occur and to infer whether a
relationship is there or not and let's
imagine that now we had a perfect system
that could extract all of them on this
text and we would have all these triples
here that represent information this is
a bit more structure is not only text
there's some structure structure here
and the interesting things to do with
these triples there is to index them
them in triple stores or knowledge
graphs and then we can use them for
question answering so for instance now
we can look at this graph and we can
answer questions such as who studied in
Cambridge located in Massachusetts or
which universities are located in mashes
through this so basically this is what
semantics relationships are and how how
we can use them a use case the typical
use case of them so this is going to be
the basic outline of my presentation I
will just briefly go through a
approaches for semantic relationship
extraction that won't I will focus on a
method which is called Smith supervisor
bootstrapping depends on how how you
want to call it then I will present a
system snowball which is based on tf-idf
weighted vectors and then I will present
another system which has proposed which
is based on word embeddings but follows
basically the same architecture as
snowball and at the end I will just show
the experimental evaluation on which I
compared both systems so this is kind of
a taxonomy of the methods that you have
for relationship extraction there are
two main how we call two main brain
jizan on extracting semantic
relationships you have the traditional
one and you have the open one the big
difference is that the tradition when
you extract precipices specified types
of relationships instance whether on the
open information extraction you just
extract all possible relationships
whether they are valid or not from a
large collection of documents and the
open information extraction started
something like 2007-2008 the automatics
already exists the traditional since
since much longer time so just going
quickly through the different methods
rule-based you can think of it just
basically like using regular expressions
with lexicons and you just build up
rules to extract relationships the good
thing about this method is that with
just a simple rules you can extract lots
of relationships and they typically they
have a high precision but a very low
recall and also the hand mint rules are
hard to maintain if you want to update
them and always go for more cases at
some point you see that it's impossible
to keep doing this table for a long time
supervised learning as all the goods and
beds of supervised learning you need
training data which it's not always easy
to get but then you can have all the fun
or all the suffering with feature
engineering and model tuning
all that cool stuff then we have
bootstrapping which I will go in more
detail further ahead but basically takes
Adventures of unlabeled data and also
you need to handle with something called
semantic drift which I will explain also
further ahead there's yet another method
called distantly supervised on which
basically it's a way to generate lots of
training data for free and how do you do
that basically it's just you go to a
knowledge base like Wikipedia and you
can have a fact extractor there from the
info box for instance that Berlin is the
capital of Germany and what you do then
is that you go to a document collection
and for every sentence that you have
Berlin and Germany you assume that that
sentence is X is holding a semantic
relationship where expresses that one
entity is the capital of the other of
course that's not true for all sentences
so the biggest problem with this is how
to filter those out but it's also
another way to get lots of training data
for free so going now into more detail
into the bootstrapping methods so
basically this is this is the the idea
of bootstrapping is it has nothing to do
with strapping from statistics and
people confuse it but the idea is just
you just give you just give what is
called seeds which basically is to name
the entities that that have a
relationship between them for instance
Google and Mountain View or SoundCloud
and Berlin both of those instances
express the relationship of the
headquarters of for instance Google is
located in Mountain View SoundCloud
Eisenberg in Berlin and the idea is like
you will look for occurrences of those
named entities in the text and then a
collection of documents you will take
the textual context where they occur and
you will use that context or context to
extract more relationships of the same
type so the challenge here is how you
can measure the similarity between the
words like headquarter HQ and base
campus main offices based in made
quarters in so those all those phrases
semantically they are they are similar
and the idea of bootstrapping x2
exploited similarity to extract more
chips for free so this is the typical
architecture of of a bootstrapping
system you have roughly four phases you
give as input the seed instances and
then what you have to do is to find for
matches of those seed and instances in
the document collections and you would
gather all the textual context where
they occur you will use those textual
contexts to generate what's called
extraction patterns you can cluster them
and you can do many things with them and
you have patterns then you'll use those
patterns to extract more relationships
and then at the end you can add them to
the seed set again and they reiterate
this process in the last step you have
always to find a way to know if your
system is going on the right direction
or not due to semantic drift when things
start to go to go a bit crazy that's why
usually you also have to score the
patterns of the instance I will show
that in more detail so this was
something that started I believe in the
late 90s and it started as a simple task
of extracting relationships of a
particular type which will be easy and
one of the one of the things I remember
reading in the papers that were
published on that time was about finding
my biomechanical categories for terms
found in biomedical journals or papers
in the late 90s then in the 2000s some
systems were proposed for extracting any
type of relationship one of the first
ones was deep published in 1999 and
actually screwiest the brain here is is
the co-founder of Google so this paper
in 1999 was published by him and he was
using the crawl of Google at the time to
find out ur and book relationships like
this book was published by by this
author it was one of the first papers
and it's interesting to read if you're
interested the second one was snowball
published in the early 2000 and it would
extract any kind of relationships based
on tf-idf weighted vector similarities
and then there was another one which is
also very popular published 2006 also -
general relationship extracts
and it was based on point point-wise
Moodle information but now I will focus
on snowball which was the one that I try
to improve okay let's go deep into
snowball again it uses the same
architecture I will try to go step by
step and to explain what's going how we
handle each of these steps in detail so
the first step is to find the seed
matches so imagine that you give as a
seed to the system Soundcloud and berlin
so the system goes through all the
sentences in a document collection and
imagine that he finds one sentence such
as the tech company SoundCloud is based
in Berlin capital of Germany so what you
want to do is from this sentence you
want to capture first three contexts the
context of the words before the first
entity between the two entities and
after the last entity and what the
system does afterwards is to build that
EIC tf-idf context a vector for each of
the contexts and you will have something
like this you have three vectors and
every match of a seed instance will be
represented by these tuples that you see
down here where you have one tf-idf
vector the first named entity another
vector the second entity and the last
vector so the first step you just
collect all the possible tuples with
this form that you have and then on the
second step you start to generate
extraction patterns using these tuples
and the way the system that is with a
very simple question go algorithm is
just a single path costing over all the
collected tuples how does this work
you have the first tuple you put it in a
single cluster alone then you take the
second tuple you compare it with the
first if the similarity is above a
threshold you keep it on that cluster if
not you put it in a second cluster and
you do that for all the collected
instances the similarity metric to
compare the tuples is based on a weight
it's based on the cosine similarity for
each of the three contexts weighted by a
value it's the formula delta T up there
so it's basically the cosine similarity
with
in the vectors how do you generate
extraction patterns then in each cluster
you have a bunch of tuples you just
average them you average it's got each
context of them so you average all the
before contexts of the between contents
and the after contests and you have a
single vector that represents an
extraction pattern so the next step is
we want to match this extraction
patterns with new stuff that we don't
know how do we do that we know that we
are extracting organization and
locations relationships so what we're
going to do we are going to extract
every text or context where we have a
named entity marked as an organization
and close by another named entity marked
as a location okay one important thing I
forgot to mention is the input for this
system needs to have the named entities
already recognized that that's crucial
you extract this context you build the
same vectors as I shown before and then
you compute the similarity to which a
distraction patterns that that were
built in the previous step and then if
the similarity is above a threshold
passing then you extract the instance
and we are doing here just thinking
about this first two steps like the fine
speed matches and generating the
extraction patterns we're just using we
are just we are just doing processing
similarities between tf-idf weighted
vectors and there's the big limitation
on doing this which is imagine that we
have these three vectors main
headquarters in is based in and as
offices in and let's assume that for
instance gene is in is a stop word so
you just take it out if you try to do
the cosine similarity in between these
vectors it will always be zero because
they don't have any common words in
common dimensions and this is the big
limitation of the tf-idf so of course
since three four years ago what you do
you use word embeddings the main
difference is now before you had a
vector that could represent a context
now for each word you have a vector and
I thought at the time okay let's try to
plug in this distribution of semantics
the word vectors into snowball
and I want to keep the same architecture
I want to keep things simple don't want
to change much so now I have the problem
of how to transform several words on
which each word as a vector into a
single vector so that architecture of
the system still holds and I'll go now
with the with the bread systems
explaining so it has the same
architecture as noble the first step is
find the seed matches and the breads
will do it in a different way so we do
the same thing
imagine that we give SoundCloud and
Berlin we look for the same for all the
sentences in the document collection
where they both occur imagine that we
found this one SoundCloud online audio
platform is based in Berlin Germany so
what we want to do now we don't each way
if we're going to use embeddings each
word here is going to be a vector and
probably there are words here that are
not important for the for the
relationships i mean online audio
platform doesn't give you much it says
what the company does but it's not
important to know that it's located in
berlin so what I thought about was to
use some patterns that are from another
system a system called reverb which does
open information extraction and
basically it restricts a relationship
between two named entities to be a verb
a verb followed by a preposition or a
verb followed by nouns adjectives
adverbs and ending in a preposition so
if we try to apply this pattern to these
sentences looking for the text between
SoundCloud and Berlin what we get is we
select just this words and this is
perfect so now the other ones we can
discard and we are just going to use
this these three words in space in a
problem with this method is okay of
course first you need to to pass the
tagger a new tag on your text and you
have the part of speech tags and then is
that we are restricting a relationship
to be mediated by
verbs on the pattern you always you
always find the variability the verb
there so but there are also
relationships for instance this one that
says that this guy is the CEO of that
company that doesn't have any verb but
we have a relationship there I mean
simple solution here what I do I just
take all of the text so and now the
problem is each of these words mark in
bold is a vector and we want to average
them or do some some other
compositionality function just to have
one single vector and what I do is
something also very simple I just remove
every word is just part of a stopped
word list and every word which is marked
as an objective and then at the end I
just some day embeddings of each word so
we had these tuples that were extracted
before now we're going to remove stop
words and objectives we get something
like this and now we're just going to
use the embeddings in this case it's
even perfect this was hand picked
examples okay but you get just one word
on the between context to get to on the
after contest for the second sentence
but you just need to sum them and yeah
okay this is clean and I'll just need to
sum them and we have again the same
tuples that you had before on the on
this original snoball system now we are
going to the second size works just
showing back we were on the first one
fine didn't find seed matches now we
went to the second one generate
extraction pattern so we have these
tuples we want to cluster them the
cluster will be done in the same way as
I explained before using also the same
similar similarity metric the problem
here is it's not actually a probe what
was a problem when I did the experiments
but what happened is that at the end we
have several tuples in each of the
clusters and I already was summing or
averaging the word embeddings of each
word and now I wanted to do it to do an
I want the cluster to be represented by
a single vector like it was on the
original snobol but what I found in this
experience is that
if I would now start to average the sum
of the word embeddings the semantics
were starting to get lost and these
things will get out of control
so I understood that I have to keep the
embeddings like they are I cannot
average them because the results are
much better so I just change the
similarity the similarity function and
the way that is defined is the
similarity between an instance and the
cluster where in the cluster we have
lots of instances is the maximum of all
the similarities between any of the
instance in the cluster so you're going
to take your tupilaq stat before and
you're going to compute the similarity
with all the instances in the cluster
and if the majority of the similarities
is higher than the threshold you say
that the similarity to that cluster is
the maximum of the similarities and and
I defined the new similarity function on
the bread systems like this and I kept
it through all the pipeline and those
were basically the two biggest plugins
that I change on the original system I
wanted to keep the rest of the
architecture as the same to keep things
simple didn't want to try out many
different things so we already went to
the first one find the seed matches
generate extraction patterns now let's
find the relationship instances it's the
same thing as before we just extract the
contexts but now when we apply the
similarity metric we are doing actually
over word embeddings and not over tf-idf
weighted vectors so again we look for
contexts we extract the text for context
we build the vectors as before and then
if the similarity with extraction
patterns is above threshold tau seam we
extracted and then here we start to
taking care of what is called a semantic
drift so what we do is we have a formula
to update the confidence of a scoring
pattern which I will just I will
describe in the next slide so imagine
that we found the new instance on the
text and we are going to extract that
instance because the similarity with
distraction patterns say so that we
should extracted in the imagine that we
are we gave as in
put on the initial seed set SoundCloud
and Berlin if the extracted instance is
also SoundCloud and Berlin then we give
a positive point to the to the pattern
because it extracted something that we
already know if for instance the
extraction patterns extract something
like SoundCloud and London for instance
then you give a negative point because
it doesn't correspond to what's on the
initial seed set if it is unknown if
it's something that we don't know we
just give an unknown point and then at
the end we compute the confidence of the
pattern using the formula above another
important thing is that for each
extracted instance that the step we can
take from the document collection we
keep track of the patterns that
extracted it and what was the similarity
score this is you'd use the head to
compute to compute the the semantic
drift so we are going now to explain how
to how to handle with the semantic drift
so what is what is the semantic drift
systematic brief happens when when
they're the new relationship instance
data racks that are being extracted
where the seed occurs but they have a
different semantics than the seed set
for instance if we give Google if you
have Google Mountain View as a seed we
can extract Google and headquarters in
Mountain View it's okay we don't restart
the locations of companies Google based
in Mountain View is also okay but the
system might match something like Google
shareholders meetings in Mountain View
and this doesn't hold that Google's
locations in in Mountain View or I mean
for me it doesn't so this can generate
extraction patterns that will start to
target other relationships types and
this starts to propagate to the
bootstrapping iterations of the system
and this just starts to drift away from
the original thing so on the on the few
slides before I told that for each
instance that you extract you keep track
of which patterns extracted it and what
was the similarity score so at the end
you're just going to apply this this
formula which is just a weighted measure
between the confidence of the pattern
and the similarity that
but that pattern had with the incident
to score the instances so every instance
extracted by the system will have a
score and at the end what you do before
adding the seed instances to the new to
the seed set you just you just take the
top the top K you set another threshold
called tau min and you say everything
above this threshold goes to the seed
set everything that's below you just
discard it and and it's finished this
how how the system works on the first
you find the seed matches you find the
context you cluster them you have
extraction patterns use the extraction
patterns to find new relationship
instances and your regular patterns and
then in the last step you will rank the
instances and then you take just a few
instances to the seed set again and they
repeat this process until to a fixed
number of iterations you can put 4 5 6
depending on the on this other side of
your document collection so I I now go
explain how I evaluated these two
systems so the first thing to do is to
find the document collection where I
could put the two systems at work so I
took English's new English new articles
from the jiggawatts collection which
basically contains five point five
minutes new articles published between
94 and 2010 I did a pre-processing of
that document collection did sentence
detection and word tokenization part of
speech tagging with a Python and ltk and
then I used the stand Fortner to tag the
named entities also over this collection
I generated word embeddings is in the
script Graham with legend five and
vectors of dimension 200 and then what I
did over this sentences s was I look at
this sentence and let's just keep the
ones that have at least two entities and
meant and those entities are mentioned
on freebase and at the end I had the
data set with 1.2 million sentences and
this was this was a document collection
to evaluate
it both systems to compare the systems
what was done before so I had I had I
had breads which I implemented the
system I also implemented snowball using
the tf-idf but with a slight Elise
change on which the words for the
between context were being selected and
then also the original snowball the
classic one and then I played around
with lots of parameters so for the Tau
seem the Tau mean either it I vary those
parameters between 0.5 and 1.10 also for
the similarity measure you always have
to wait the context I basically play
around with two schemas one which just
considerate the between context and then
the second one which also considered the
before and the after context but with
the lower eighth and I did the
experiment for four types of
relationships acquired means like one
company acquire the other founders like
who was the founder of which company the
headquarters where with this each
company has dead quarters and the
affiliation which people work for for
which company and okay I left is just
running on the machine for one week
almost and then at the end you just
collect the results you compare them and
okay this is lots of information I'll
just go quickly so basically here on the
first column just have the number of
instance extracted by each system you
can see that breads extract much more
special for the affiliation relationship
and also with a good precision and
recall it bit it bit all all the other
systems I mean I saw this I was happy
and then I start to understanding what
why I wanted to see more of the results
and basically what happens as I was
expected is due to the to the way that
the embeddings work when you try to find
similarities between the words you can
expand it to more words for instance
breads could could expand the vocabulary
for the acquires relationships to
acquired acquisition processed by /as
portraits of the founders they also
expanded
and special affiliation this is these
are just the the top words use it that
the system used to extract relationships
but you can see clearly that given just
two seeds so every for every
relationship I only gave two seeds and
that based on those two seeds for
especially for the affiliation I could
get much more related words that
quad-core with those and the other
systems due to being based on tf-idf
they just got got stuck on those on
those simple words nevertheless there is
still some improvement that can be done
on bread so the thing is beyond we I'm
using part of speech tags just to find
the relationships between two entities
are the words that mediate and most of
the times or for all mode yeah half of
the times that's not enough depending on
how the relationship expressed in the
sentence for instance International
Court of Justice which is part of the
United Nations is based in the egg if we
are going to to look for the
relationship between United Nations in
the egg what we have is the United
Nations is based in the egg which is
wrong this is not what the sentence is
saying this is deeply wrong this is
because of using only part of speech
tagging and this this kind of errors can
only be evaluated if you go to synthetic
dependencies if we try to understand
what are the relationships between the
words not what what is the function of
the word in the sentence but how are the
words connected to each other and if you
look here the word base connects the AG
hugger
with the International Court of Justice
which is what the sentence is saying the
International Court of Justice is based
in The Hague another improvement that I
could do is instead of using only named
entity recognizes which it just it's
just a surface string it just takes the
string as being a person or location
organization will be to to pre-process
the document collection with something
called entity linking on which when you
see George Bush the system could tell
based on the context if that entity
named George Bush is George Bush the
father or George Bush
son or whether if you just see the word
Bush is George Bush the father the son
it's the band Bush or if it's a company
called Bush I mean the many adventures
of this is that then you can instead of
giving them string names we have to be
to give identifiers to entities but you
have much more contexts where those
entities occur because the same entity
can be mentioned by different surface
strings and the system was then already
aware of this and yeah and that that's
it you have the I have both of the
systems implemented on the github and
and also have the paper where I explain
much more in detail how the system works
and yeah I hope at least I can convince
you to go and read the paper thank you
[Applause]
any questions and on the slide
evaluation see the system's the next
this one yeah how did you decide on the
context weighting the alpha beta and
gamma did you do some kind of
optimization to find which one was the
best or did you just randomly no no what
I did was I had I had a feeling that in
the between context it was where the
relation was expressed but I also wanted
to explore the other ones I just say
okay let's let's put it like this okay
one other thing is that I could do a
third one whilst was to give one third
of a to which the context and see which
one occurs but I mean especially if you
are young using part of speech tags to
extract relationships I will say that
most of the times the words that mediate
the relationship are in the between
context okay so you just pick these
weights and say okay their optimal did
you try different ones no I didn't I
didn't I just it was like it was like
this I didn't yeah okay
thank you for a talk and I was wondering
what is the or what are the bottlenecks
of this algorithm because he said it was
running for a week
what why like the bottlenecks yeah okay
there's those two that I referred using
only the parts of speech tags and
there's another big one which is related
I didn't put it on the slides actually
but I know when I was working with it
which is where is it it's here this is
not so easy to understand but you see
how the way that you are ranking
patterns limits away for instance in
this case you are extracting if you
stretch relationships for instance like
Google headquarters basically every
company only has one headquarters but
you can have relationships that are not
unique let me think about I don't know
imagine that you know it's not the
headquarters of companies but
installations or or or or settlements of
companies some companies can have
offices all over the world what happens
you imagine that sound cloud for
instance which was one of the seats had
that if you extract something from the
text like SoundCloud also has offices in
Berlin but you didn't give it as a seed
the pattern will be ranked or wrongly
but that will not be correct because you
also want that so what you want is this
the way that this formula here is used
to rank patterns needs to be changed
because this this is a limitation is a
weakness here I don't know if it was
clear if you understand with an example
I can explain to offline I can show yeah
yeah but I know I know that here was one
another one of the biggest weakest of
the system
yeah I have a question about kind of how
Punk can time people into this models
for example relationships relationships
can change over time first of all you
said there are and even there might be a
Ramada polish that is George Bush
problem yet in like year 2000 probably
George Bush it depends on the year of
the first ababa news article which yet
first it might refer to or affiliations
much change over time yeah okay one
thing is you just want to extract what
is correct based on the documents the
documents it's the collection of news
articles from 94 to 2010 so what's
written there let's assume it's valid
for that time period that's I mean
there's nothing else that you can do one
thing that I find interesting was when I
was evaluating these relationships I did
a bigger experience for this this is
another paper but on my thesis on
there's one chapter where I did much
more experiences and I was extracting a
relationship was who is the who is the
president or the CEO of companies and
one of our organizations among others
that's that's it extracted from these
documents from 94 to 2010 was one
document from two thousand seven or
eight on which the president of FIFA was
one guy but then when I compared with
the information on freebase to validate
the relationships freebase was more
actual and the President had changed so
actually he strutted the correct
relationship from a document but the
evaluation said it was wrong because
that information was up until 2010 and
freeways was a knowledge base updated
like I mean early or something like that
that was I mean but but the main goal of
the system you just extract what's on
the documents you don't to validate
whether that in the real life is valid
or not that's another problem we just
want to extract what is being said on
the document
thank you for your talk
others the system deals with the fact
that two people can have the same name
but actually do something different for
example like Michael Jordan is a bass is
a basketball player but there's also
Michael Jordan the researcher yeah I
mean it doesn't that's that's why I put
it doesn't deal with that that's why I
put instead of using simply named entity
recognition let's prep process the
document collection with an entity
linking system and then instead of
giving just Michael Jordan and Anna
theme to which it plays you give the IDS
of each of the entities and the text
should know that those IDs correspond
hello great talk
I will enjoy it and I had like two
little questions one is a the way you
define similarity that's like it is not
normalized like it could and you put
like in a snowball part yeah the way you
do it like it may be difficult to
compare different different things with
that similarity I think is the gap is
not you I think at you is it possible
you may need to normalize it to be able
to compare it with other similarities
that's one thing and the other thing is
the way you chose the thresholds for the
for the keep in their relationships yeah
okay the similarity I didn't normalize
them I just use the vectors as they are
so I mean I don't know how how big of an
influence it could be to normalize them
but I didn't in the experiments for the
for the thresholds what I did so
basically have your threshold stomp out
simple mean what I did was I explored on
the system all the combinations of them
so tau seem equals to 0.5 and then tau
min equals to zero point 5 6 7 8 9 so I
use this so it's like 6 times 6 possible
values then times 2
config' awaiting configurations and
times for relationships this was not
clear on the system but I left this
running on the server for almost like
one week doing all this in parallel it
took so but yeah I mean I didn't export
threshold values below 0.5 I just I mean
I don't think that would make much sense
just started from 0.5 to 1.0 yeah
another question so you added this new
similarity where you don't use an
average vectors but then academics the
best best fitting one yeah
have you tried like if you use this
approach with normal tf-idf vectors does
it approve as well a good question it
might I don't know good but yeah a good
question I don't I think when you
average stuff and you average over
average it starts to lose semantics of
stuff yeah yeah
thank you if no other question then
let's think David again for his
wonderful talk
[Applause]